- Eat the meat jello.
Eat the meat jello.
Eat--
(Russian folk music)
- So, I wasn't planning
on making this video,
but the other day I was
shooting with my mom,
and just like any typical
Jewish-Russian mom,
all she could focus on was feeding me.
So, she brought me Holodets,
which is a traditional Russian dish.
It's just meat engulfed in its own fat.
She loves it.
I don't know why; I hate it.
This is what happened.
Mom, I'm not having it.
- There.
- Mom, no, no.
- No means no, okay?
- There; there.
- Mom, no, I'm not having it.
- There.
- Just try it; if you don't
like it, you can spit it out.
Just try it.
- [Female Voice] Chew, Eric.
- You know what?
You should let your friends
in the office try it.
Because I know that
everybody's gonna like it.
You'd be nuts.
- Oh, you think everybody's gonna like it?
- Yes, I think so.
- Okay, you wanna make a bet?
- Well--
- All right, what are we betting?
- We'll bet that if they
like it, you eat it.
- Oh, if they like it, I eat it, okay.
- Yeah, you eat the whole thing.
- And if they don't like it?
- And if they don't like it, I'll eat it.
- (snorts) What?
You like it.
No, if they don't like it,
I never have to eat this ever again.
- That's fine, agreed.
(Russian folk music)
Hi.
- Oh my god, hello.
- Hi, I'm Eric's mom.
- Oh my god.
- Hi, I've heard so much about you.
- I brought in a little lunch.
Excuse me.
Hi, sorry to bother you.
I'm Eric's mom, and we made
a little bet with Eric.
I brought him lunch.
- Eric, are you serious?
You're seriously bringing
your mom into this?
- Is this a big bite?
Is this too much?
- [Mom] This is perfect.
- This is a good-sized bite.
- It's a really good bite.
- To Eric's family.
Uh-hmmm.
- [Mom] You have to get used to it.
- Thank you so much.
- Good?
- Achoo.
- Not bad, right?
- Huh-uh.
- What do you think?
- It literally just tastes
like chicken and jello.
- [Mom] Yeah, you like it?
- It tastes like chicken and jello.
- We eat it with horseradish and bread.
So can I put a little horseradish,
and you'll give it a try?
- I honestly think that would help.
- Yes, okay, let me get it.
- Buddy, I need to get out of here.
- This is made out of chicken fat.
Like, I don't think this is real jello
that you get in the store.
I don't taste the strawberry, the cherry.
- Texturally, I thought
I was about to die.
- Wait until you try it with horseradish.
This is for you dissolve it.
And like this.
Okay?
And you take a piece of black bread.
- Black bread?
- Black bread.
- This is black bread.
Is it whole wheat or anything?
- It's made out of black something.
I'm not exactly sure.
- Got it.
- So first that.
- First this.
- [Both] And then that.
- Gotcha.
- Second time. (surprised whimper)
- (groan of disgust)
I mean, this is great.
- Good, right?
- Did you make this yourself?
- Yes.
(chuckles)
- Yeah, I get it.
- This is literally just horseradish.
- Horseradish definitely helps.
- Yes, yes, you know what would help?
Vodka.
- Vodka?
- Yes.
- I thought I just ate a shot of vodka.
- This afternoon has
gone from zero to 100.
Oh, this is your typical
Russian shot glass?
- So, the bet is that if you like it,
Eric is gonna eat the whole thing.
- Oh well, I love it.
- Yeah, this is really good.
- I love it, Eric.
Now you have to eat some.
- So, did you guys like it?
(all exclaim in agreement)
- [Coworker] It was delicious.
(all chatter in agreement)
- [Coworker] That bread?
To die for.
- Eat the meat.
Eat the meat jello.
(Coworkers chatter)
- Why is there vodka in there?
(all exclaim in disgust)
- Oh, come on, you've got to be strong.
- You still have to eat it all.
- I'm done; I'm done.
No, I'm quitting.
- [Coworker] Your food's delicious.
You're son's a piece of (bleep).
(all laugh)